This website got over 1.7 million
impressions in the AI search mode and
the AI overview mode on Google.
You can now actually track your AI
search impressions on Google Search
Console. You can see how your website is
doing in terms of showing up on AI
search and showing up on AI overview.
So, if you go over to learn more, we can
actually see this new rollout and see
exactly how it works. So, we now have
the generative AI performance report in
our Search Console. So, what's included
is our AI overview, so how many times
your website is showing up in AI
overviews, and how many times your
website is showing up in the AI search
mode. As of now, we can see the pages,
we can see the countries, devices, and
your impressions per day. Now, we don't
have clicks, we just have impressions,
but for now, this gives us a lot of
great data that we can work with. But,
we can see for this client site that
I've showed you many, many tutorials on
this channel is doing extremely well in
AI search. In the past 3 months,
it's got in over 1.7 million
impressions. And if you scroll on to
pages, we can actually take a look at
the pages to see which pages are showing
up more in AI search. We can then
optimize those pages, or we can take
what's working in those pages and apply
it to our other pages. Now, a lot of you
say that, you know, SEO is dead,
blogging is dead, but if we go ahead and
we take a look at this
report here, we can see that most of the
AI search mode and AI overviews are from
blog posts.
So, blog posts and blogging definitely
still works in 2026 and beyond. You may
not rank on Google, but you will show up
in AI search. And this is the
competitive advantage that you will have
if you continue to focus on growing your
SEO. So, we can see here all of these
blogs, these informational blogs, is
what's showing up in AI search mode. And
naturally, when someone sees something
in AI search mode, of course, they're
going to naturally go over to your
website.
So, you can see also the countries. So,
you can see which countries were getting
the most impressions from AI. And we can
see again, United States, United
Kingdom, really, really um high-quality
audiences. And these are the audiences
that buy things from your website. So,
we can see a bunch of other countries as
well, but we're ranking the highest in
the United States and the United
Kingdom.
We can also see our devices and our
days. So, if you actually go ahead and
open up some of these articles here, we
can take a look at it. And as you guys
can tell, all of these articles were
generated using my tool Wordtracker.
Now, if you haven't used Wordtracker
before, it is the best SEO and GO
optimize writer in the world. And you
can see it by the stats, right? I'm not
just saying this, it actually works. You
guys see all the content here that I
generated on this website, it follows a
very, very similar pattern, right? These
images, you can tell it's Wordtracker.
You can tell the key takeaways are from
Wordtracker.
You know, if we scroll down here, we can
see the images there. These are all
images from Wordtracker.
These are older posts, so we've actually
got an even better writing SEO optimized
content using Wordtracker. As you can
see here, this has a nice custom HTML
embedded as well. So, Wordtracker
definitely works. Blogging still works.
And if you want to get ahead in 2026 and
beyond and have a competitive advantage
and show up in AI search, then I highly,
highly recommend you do research, you do
your keyword research to find what
people are searching on. And then you
use a tool like Wordtracker to write the
actual content for you. And you rinse
and repeat that. And as you can see for
this website, this website has over 600
blog posts. So, it's not a small amount
of blog posts that we generate. We
generate a lot of blog posts on a
month-to-month basis, but we can see
here that that blogging has paid off,
and this website is reaping the benefit
of getting a lot of impressions from AI
Search and ranking in AI Search mode and
AI overview. If again, if we take a look
at the Ahrefs data, we see as well that
this website is ranking in AI Search.
So, if you want to get similar results
for your website, I definitely recommend
using our tool WordLift to write your
content. If you want to see where you
currently stand, just make sure you set
up Google Search Console if you haven't
before, and then head over to search
results, and then scroll down to
generative AI, and you should be able to
see some information. If you don't see
information, then that just means that
your website doesn't have enough
rankings cuz it is rolling out
um to bigger and bigger sites, and it
will eventually be available for most
sites. Hope that you guys enjoyed this
quick video. If you did, let me know by
giving us a big thumbs up, and I'll see
you in the next video.
I've went ahead and created a skill,
which does an audit of your niche and
your website, and then gives you
keywords that are AI Search relevant
like fan out keywords that you can use
to then write in WordLift. So, you can
create a plan of writing on content to
help you get more impressions in AI
Search and AI overview. So, if you want
to go ahead and get this skill, just
comment generative below, and I'll send
it over to you.